Elite athletes.
How many of them actually want to fight?
Who's the most elite athletes in the UFC?
I think y'all Romero.
Yes.
100% and he's a wrestler.
Cuba and Cuban.
It's either boxing or wrestling.
Yeah,
but remember you.
Al Romero is a freak in.
So amazing because he came to MMA at what?
35 yeah.
30 oh zero is going to be 62 years old.
Walking on the beach with a Dick,
like a fucking Quaker oats box.
Hey,
between his direct dude,
he's fighting a fucking homeboy.
The other Diana's Paula Costa.
Eddie Bravo that says the fucking tweet that day.
What did he say?
He just sent it to the list,
but it's hilarious.
Some private shit.
I didn't make that.
It was,
I mean you don't mind me than I know,
but still we got a little room to Jamie right now.
It's fucking great.
I just make the meme up.
Who is this guy?
You never take JW Kaiser.
I don't do meetings.
He some guy's about to get fucked up.
Brian don't need to download his information.
Yeah,
the guy coming up.
Jack Swagger's the guy you should probably take notice.
Okay.
I'm not happy.
I'm not mad at the bell tour.
Girls not mad at all,
dude.
Mercedes not mad at at all.
My,
yeah.
Wow.
Paula Costa and your Yoel Romero for sure have the best body
pulling another pound.
Yeah,
but Luke Rockhold is longer and thinner is beautiful and all that bottle is
beautiful,
but there's a big difference.
He doesn't want the gorilla look at this.
[inaudible]
it's a fucking great.
Eddie said that just today.
We're fun outright.
No,
but she said [inaudible] not make that didn't make it fucking with it.
I agree with it.
I sent it
to the UFC.
I agree with it.
I don't even want to know what to say right now.
I'm fucking,
let me say that Shit.
You stay up there.
I'm trying to get fired.
[inaudible] call me in this week to do fucking the breakdown.
Shit.
Fight breakdowns.
I think you shot a test tube and I think that you've got a belt or tattoo in his
back.
Oh shit he does.